[Music]
today it is finally time to check out
amd's rx
6800 xt which is their answer to
nvidia's rtx 3080
and man does this thing pack a punch amd
are claiming that this card
is faster than the 3080 while pulling a
bit less power
and costing 50 less on paper this thing
sounds like the perfect
rtx 3080 killer and there's only one
thing left to do at this point
and that's to see if that's actually the
case
now most of you have probably studied
the spec sheet inside and out by this
point but for those of you who haven't
here's what we're working with
the 6800 xt comes packed with 72 compute
units on amd's new 7 nanometer rd and a2
architecture
and a whopping 16 gigabytes of gddr6
memory it's the middle child in the
family for now and
starting at 649 us dollars this is
definitely positioned as an
enthusiast-class
gaming gpu and we've already taken a
good look at amd's new cooler design in
our previous video
and which cases this will and won't fit
in and later on we'll take a look at the
therma and noise performance as well
for now though let's dive right into the
benchmarks let's start off with red dead
redemption 2
a very popular title running the vulcan
api which amd gpus have historically
played really well with
and this game is absolutely no exception
not only is the average
fps clearly beating the rtx 3080 here
but the frame rate stability was the
real standout when we take a look at the
graphs we can see exactly what that
looks like
at 1440p the 6800 xt is around three
percent faster when it comes to the
average frame rate but a massive
53 percent faster when it comes to the
slowest one percent of frame rate the
gaming experience delivered here would
also be better than
the 30 90. bumping the resolution up to
4k
those 1 percent lows are still extremely
strong but the 3080
now takes the lead on average by over 11
look out for this trend in the future
graphs as well generally the 6800 xt
does a bit better at 1440p
than 4k whereas it's the reverse for the
3080 which does better relatively at 4k
in shadow of the tomb raider the 6800 xt
and 3080 were extremely close
the rtx 3080 leads here by a few fps on
average
but it's also the slightly more
expensive card and no
your eyes aren't playing tricks on you
there are clear visual differences
between the amd and nvidia gpus
with nvidia opting for a more contrasty
image with
more saturation all of this footage by
the way has been recorded completely
externally with the same recorder
at 4k there's a mere two percent
performance difference between the two
on average
and less than one percent for the lowest
one percent of frame rate when we switch
to 1440p the 6800 xt just edges out on
average
but this time it's the nvidia card that
has the slight lead when it comes to
frame rate stability
in star wars jedi fallen order this was
one of the bigger margins that we see in
favor
for the rtx 3080 at 1440p we see a six
percent lead on average here for the
nvidia gpu
but when we switch to 4k that lead grows
to 25
this isn't the most optimized of games
but that is
definitely what i'd call a night and day
difference but
then we have death stranding running at
4k and here the 6800 xt
beats the 3080 by a few percent so it's
clear at this point that the results
are mixed depending on which game you're
playing and at what resolution
here the gaming experience would be
about the same between the two with the
6800 xt leading by 4
on average as we've seen though this gpu
does a lot better at 1440p
and there it can almost deliver
performance on par with the rtx 3090
for a 650 gpu the price to performance
here is simply outstanding
but then the results flip back around
rainbow six running the vulcan api has
the rtx 3080 ahead by seven percent at
4k
but the two are much closer at 1440p
lowest one percent of frame rate is
eight percent faster here for the 3080
but with both cards north of 250 frames
per second here the gaming experience
would be virtually identical between
them
when it comes to battlefield v the rx
6800 xt
dominated this game and even at 4k
managed to outpace the rtx 3080
dropping the resolution to 1440p average
frame rate is about tied here with
nvidia's 1500
rtx 3090 and you might have noticed at
this point that i've staggered the order
of the games depending on whether the
6800 xt or 3080 has the lead
that is very deliberate because that's
basically how this story plays out
between these two gpus for
most titles in the end it really is
going to depend on which games you're
playing
for now though let's shift our
discussion to ray tracing
amd's rdna 2 architecture is the first
to feature ray tracing support in games
that have it implemented
and as we know this has been a serious
investment on nvidia's behalf
so here we're looking at control running
with the
xt and the 3080 at 1440p without
raytracing enabled and the 3080 leads
here on average by just under 5
when we enable ray tracing on both gpus
it's clear which of these cards has
dedicated ray tracing silicon
both cards take a pretty big frame rate
hit but it's the 30 80 which is almost
50 percent faster in the end of course
there are limited titles with decent ray
tracing support but it's
definitely something that you'll want to
keep in mind especially for future games
like cyberpunk 2077
furthermore nvidia's secret weapon dlss
2.0
this allows the rtx 3080 to render the
game
at a lower resolution then upscale it
using deep learning
with it enabled the 3080 gets a 60
frame rate boost with no visual
downgrade and you still have those ray
trace reflections
f1 2020 is another title where nvidia's
dlss
is definitely worth enabling offering a
frame rate boost over the stock rtx 3080
performance
able to overtake both the 6800 xt and
even the stock rtx 3090 here
to be fair amd have the slightly better
outright gpu
rasterization performance here but they
really do need to come up with their own
version of dlss
and quick at the moment the supported
games are slim but the list
is rapidly growing and the performance
difference here with it enabled is
simply huge in fact amd's outright gpu
performance is
more impressive when we consider how
little power the 6800 xt
actually pulls at full load total system
power at the wall was measured at just
424 watts that's over 50 watts
less than the rtx 3080. this is even
more impressive in the context of gpu
clock speeds which were the fastest that
i've seen
on any gpu that i've reviewed higher
clock speeds require higher voltages to
stabilize which in turn means higher
power consumption
so in terms of performance per watt the
6800 xt is
absolutely stomping the rtx 3080.
thermals were also
very well managed the gpu temp
stabilized at around 75 degrees c on an
open test bench with a room ambient of
22c
with the gpu hotspot safely sitting at
around 95c
fan speed was also very low at just 1250
rpm
here's an idea of what that sounded like
finally let's close off with some
production workloads
in blender we're limited to using opencl
as opposed to cuda on nvidia gpus
and that means that render times are
around 30 slower than the rtx 3080 in
this scene
however when we bump up the resolution
and sample count the 6800 xt is now 42
percent slower
then it only gets worse from there when
we factor in nvidia's more optimized
optics renderer the 6800 xt will take
130 percent longer than the rtx 3080.
when it comes to v-ray as far as i know
this does support
opencl but the 6800 xt just couldn't be
found on this system
so if you do use your system for 3d art
i'd say you'd be better off with a 3080
this also includes renderers like octane
and redshift which only work
exclusively with nvidia gpus but there
is
really good news when it comes to video
editing just as you can encode videos
with the h.265 encoder on nvidia gpus
you can do the same with the 6800 xt and
it's actually pretty damn fast in fact i
found it to be on par with the rtx 1390
when it came to export times here which
is super impressive
video stabilization time was a bit
slower though so
your actual workflow might be a little
bit slower depending on the program and
effects that you're using
and i won't forget to mention that the
6800 xt has a huge
16 gigabytes of video memory to play
with that does give it
a lot more headroom when it comes to
higher resolution footage over the 30
80. but here's where things
don't look so great if you're someone
who enjoys recording gameplay and
capturing highlights and replays
you'll be making your life a lot easier
with an nvidia gpu
amd's radeon relive has been a huge
gamble depending on which card you're
using it with
and the implementation for the 6800 xt
is
simply broken even just enabling the
instant replay functionality in the
background causes
huge repeated stutters at fixed
intervals in games
and when you go back and watch one of
those replays the file is somehow
corrupted
and i'd love to say that this would be
fixed in a future driver update
but it never is i still see issues like
this even today with the 5700 xt's
amd's smart access memory is something
that i've skipped for this review but it
is something that i plan to dedicate a
full video on
this allows ryzen 5000 series cpus to
share the memory on
radeon 6000 gpus when plugged into a 500
series motherboard
for a slight performance boost amd's own
claims here are
mixed but the average claimed
performance gain seems around five
percent
so then rtx 3080 or the new rx 6800 xt
well i think it's clear that these two
gpus when it comes to gaming performance
are fairly evenly matched
the rtx 3080 is generally better at 4k
although not exclusively and the 6800xt
seems like the better pick for 1440p
gamers if you are just a casual gamer
that wants a big upgrade in frame rate
then
your best bet is probably just to choose
the most affordable one in your region
which
is most likely the 6800 xt or the one
that's simply in stock
ultimately it is the radeon 6800 xt
that's the best choice when it comes to
gaming performance for the money and
also gaming
performance per watt but i can't help
but feel that with the rtx 3080
you are actually getting your money's
worth for that extra 50 dollars
you will be able to record your games
with nvidia's shadow play
boost your frame rate by a significant
amount with dlss in a few titles
you'll also be able to stream your games
with their onboard envence encoder
and also have cuda support in production
workloads these
aren't fluff features some users would
easily consider these to be
deal breakers so if you can't live
without those features then it's the rtx
if not then more power to you save the
50 and go with the 6800 xt
you are getting a seriously impressive
gpu here amd's rdna 2 architecture is
absolutely no joke especially with the
performance per
watt that was seriously surprising to
see i will have
both of these linked down below so you
can check pricing and availability in
your region
as always a huge thanks for watching and
i'll see you all
in the next one